mister wireless è un nomignolo che mi
hanno cucito addosso alcuni anni fa in
occasione del quello che è stato il
primo lavoro che abbiamo fatto per in
qualche modo di mostrare che si poteva
utilizzare la tecnologia povera ma ben
fatta ben dimensionata ben organizzata
per portare internet laddove internet
non c'è ormai me lo tengo perché l'hanno
utilizzato il giornale l'ha notato le tv
ovviamente potete immaginare quanto mi
prendono in giro gli amici per questo
però oramai è così possiamo predire una
presentazione
ok allora ho pensato di organizzare
questi dieci minuti di chiacchierata
facendo di vedere come si può fare
ricerca nel nostro paese praticamente
senza denaro anche perché siamo
costretti a fare ricerca nel nostro
paese senza denaro e sfogliando un
calendario che comincia nel 2004 quando
insieme con una persona che all'epoca
era un mio studente
abbiamo deciso di portare avanti una
realizzazione che doveva coronare un
sogno che era quello di dimostrare che
si poteva lavorare ad alta tecnologia
con costi molto contenuti e magari
riuscendo anche a fare delle
realizzazioni che avessero anche una
finalità sociale una finalità utile
tenendo conto che la gran parte dei
sistemi di telecomunicazione sapete bene
che sono stati inventati invece
fondamentalmente principalmente almeno
l'inizio con finalità di tipo militare
allora nel 2004
adesso la foto che ci diranno sì è tanto
bene ma in questo laboratorio che
abbiamo chiamato i sem stato fondato a
quattro mani e quattro zampe e le
quattro zampe sono quelle del mio
coinquilino che era nato l'anno prima e
che mi accompagnava tutti i sabati in
ufficio perché rapì con avevo intenzione
di lasciarlo da solo a casa e le quattro
mani sono le due mani e con le due di
riccardo stefanelli che il primo nella
foto che rappresenta i componenti del
laboratorio adesso è che appunto ci
trovavamo il sabato in laboratorio lui
stava iniziando a fare qualche
progettino qualche piccola intership
diciamo che abbiamo condiviso fin
dall'inizio l'idea che era alla base di
quel principio che vi ho espresso prima
come e quando siamo riusciti a portarla
a metterlo in atto a metterla in pratica
è stato agli inizi del 2005 e l'abbiamo
fatto in quello che io considero il
posto più bello del pianeta e non per
altro non perché ci sono nato non perchè
ci vivo e ovviamente no assolutamente
che il comune di verrua savoia nel
monferrato quindi nelle colline
piemontesi dove nel 2005
stiamo parlando di otto anni fa non solo
non c'era la connettività a banda larga
come in tanti posti in italia all'epoca
ma nessuno ce la voleva portare perché
sostenevano che costava troppo e perché
sostenevano che se l'avessero fatto una
realizzazione e portato internet in quel
posto all'epoca poi gli operatori non
avrebbero ottenuto una rendita economica
così come se l'enel negli anni 20 negli
anni trenta avesse pensato che si dovrà
portare l'elettricità esclusivamente
nelle città perché in campagna non
avrebbe reso o se gli acquedotti fossero
stati costruiti solo per la città di
roma milano torino venezia e firenze
perché in tutte le altre non avrebbero
potuto rientrare degli investimenti
purtroppo le telecomunicazioni sono si
sono sviluppati in italia troppo
recentemente quando alcune politiche di
discutibile privatizzazione avevano
ormai rovinato quello che è il principio
di base e cioè che i servizi dovrebbero
essere portati a tutti e che la
valutazione della rendita economica dei
servizi dovrebbe essere misurata su
scala nazionale e non su una scala
tale e contingente va bene allora nel
2005 il sindaco del mio comune mi
incontra per strada e mi dice mi hanno
chiesto 30 mila euro per portare
internet qua come faccio non li ho se
spendo 30 mila euro non riesco più ad
asfaltare le strade e io ho detto vabbè
proviamo facciamo qualcosa noi abbiamo
preso un po di pezzi in laboratorio
abbiamo preso quella roba là che era un
vecchio computer che non utilizzeranno
più per fare simulazioni l'abbiamo
rielaborato abbiamo costruito un codice
abbastanza sofisticato ma poi alla fine
montato su componenti vedete lo stato in
cui versava quella roba lì abbiamo
utilizzato per realizzare un sistema di
ponti di trasmissione che
fondamentalmente avevano all'interno dei
comuni router wireless come quelli che
avete nelle vostre case e a primo nel
maggio del 2005 il primo hot spot e
quelli che adesso vanno di moda e che
all'epoca però non ce n'erano molti
soprattutto in campania
era il primo aperto al di fuori della
città di torino in piemonte connettività
per tutti connettività gratuita perché
si doveva essere ovviamente un esempio
uno stimolo in meno di un mese
raggiungeremo 80 persone che accettavano
di andare in piazza al freddo tra
l'altro perché quel maggio figure freddo
per collegarsi alla rete per disporre
della connettività allora quindi qualche
cosa si poteva fare e si poteva fare
anche pensando di lavorare a costo basso
e magari utilizzando un know how
sofisticato per realizzare alcune cose
per cui la regione piemonte si accorse
di noi e nel 2006 ci diede un
piccolissimo contributo economico ma
tant era diciamo riuscire a portare
avanti un progetto che prevedeva
all'unione di tutta una serie di
istituti scolastici ovviamente in posti
sfigatissimi quindi nel
tra accompagna colline eccetera eccetera
dove i bambini non avevano la
possibilità di lavorare su internet
fu un'esperienza straordinaria tutti i
miei studenti furono coinvolti e la cosa
bella era che quando portammo la
connessione per la prima volta furono i
bambini che non avevano mai utilizzato
una webcam ad insegnare alle loro
maestre come si andava su internet cosa
si poteva fare 100 potete immaginare poi
problemi annessi e connessi
dovemmo difatti quell'anno organizzare
dei corsi all'università della terza età
venivano anche alcune maestre perché poi
insegnavamo cosa si poteva fare con un
computer e cosa si poteva fare su
internet
allora questo fu un'esperienza
interessante che ebbe poi un corollario
carino perché con la nostra stessa
tecnologia ci venne chiesto di
realizzare la copertura wireless
integrale del museo del cinema che ha
ospitato la mole antonelliana a torino e
fu il primo museo completamente coperto
da wifi nella zona del torinese
ovviamente adesso ci sono altri sistemi
molto più sofisticati non quelle
scazzeri e che avevamo montato
all'inizio però comunque l'idea era che
anche un progetto complesso e poi
funziona molto bene facevano didattica a
distanza lo si poteva fare con
tecnologia povero ovviamente però con il
know how adeguato
allora sulla scorta di questi primi
esperimenti e io fui contattato al tra
la fine del mese inizio nel 2007 da
alcune ng uno in particolare voleva in
africa utilizzare i nostri sistemi però
incontrare alcune volte mi dissero
carino interessante fatte delle cose
belle ma secondo noi non funzionano
perché una volta che dobbiamo portare in
africa non andranno perché
il clima è diverso perché le condizioni
mentali sono diverse perché le distanze
sono più grandi delle vostre e quindi
scelsero di allestire quel progetto che
avevano sul quale stavano lavorando
senso di allestire una connettività di
tipo satellitare col satellite
funzionano qualche mese dopo di che poi
era così complesso il fatto di
collegarsi a satellite che nessuno sul
posto lo sapeva poi sistemare aggiustare
modificare cambiare le configurazioni e
quindi l'esperimento è il progetto fini
allora per dimostrare che i nostri cose
non andavano bene solo berla savoia e
dintorni ma anche un po più lontano
decidemmo di partecipare a una
competizione in particolare decidemmo un
bene la buttiamo lì è un po come si dice
da sboroni però fortunatamente andò bene
perché decidemmo di realizzare il
collegamento via wireless con tecnologia
povera più lungo che fosse mai stato
tentato fino a quel momento 300
chilometri collegando le alpi con gli
appennini
allora ci mettiamo a lavorare su questa
cosa struttura amo tutta una rete che
doveva attraversare le alpi andare dal
politecnico di torino passar ovviamente
per averlo savoia salire sulla capanna
margherita sul monte rosa
in questo posto bellissimo che vedete
rappresentato qua a 4.500 56 metri sul
livello del mare e poi da lì doveva
continuare arrivare agli appennini
andare in austria io sono uno sciatore
quindi tutti questi posti erano scelti
in modo tale che ci fosse una località
sciistica carina nelle vicinanze e
ovviamente lo stesso principio quindi
montare della roba che però doveva
dimostrare di essere di poter essere
fatta con semplicità di poter durare a
condizioni quasi estreme è però essere
montata con componenti che devono
costare poco ci mettemmo un laboratorio
costruimmo delle cose quella immagine
che vedete sulla sulla sinistra fu
ripresa addirittura dai quotidiani
nazionali su repubblica le mani di
riccardo che il mio co founder del
laboratorio che giravano tutto il
pianeta senza che nessuno sapesse che ci
fosse il quello invece un momento in cui
stava montando uno dei trasmettitori
utilizzando la carta stagnola per
proteggerlo che avevamo recuperato nel
ristorante del rifugio
ovviamente non fu l'unico episodio di
montaggio in condizioni al limite quello
sono io che sto portando un pezzo di
antenne in seggiovia a questi sono le
guide alpine che si stavano quasi
immolando pur di montare un antenna sul
balcone del rifugio e questo sono ancora
io che mentre loro stavano rischiando la
vita
vedete gli scarponi da sci è però
comunque stava programmando un
trasmettitore appollaiato su una sedia
praticamente a ridosso del balcone
stesso questo è un momento molto carino
perché quando scendemmo il primo hot
spot wifi all'interno del rifugio e fu
lo spot più alto d'europa perché
ovviamente nessuno ci potrà superare
monte rosa della terza vetta d'europa
quindi c'era poco da fare
e la seconda però noi eravamo sulla
seconda del monte rosa quindi la terza e
con chiamo un moto che divenne uno dei
nostri morti perché riusciamo a
realizzare un collegamento 300
chilometri portando una banda notevole
30 megabit e alla fine spendemmo con
poco più di tre euro cioè solo il
biglietto alla seggiovia costava di più
però comunque non tanto di più e va bene
avevamo i numeri per dimostrare se si
poteva fare qualcosa in condizioni
estreme
nel 2008 partecipiamo un bando della
banca interamericana per lo sviluppo di
washington
presentiamo un progetto per realizzare
una rete internet in amazzonia 80
progetti presentati cominciamo
adesso pure era che bisogna andarci in
amazzonia e bisognava anche dimostrare
che eravamo in grado di far lavorare gli
autoctoni e anche di trasferire loro il
nostro contenuto tecnologico allora
visto che mi avevano criticato veneto è
sì tanto bravi andate voi fin quando ci
siete voi funziona allora io non ci
andai presi degli studenti appena
diplomati laureati e manda il solo loro
per dimostrare che gli autoctoni
potevano essere formati anche da gente
con competenze che non derivassero da
anni e anni di esperienza la zona era
questa è la zona di porta francisco de
orellana che sul fiume coca il villaggio
dove andammo a lavorare il villaggio di
daih um che rappresentato sulla destra
lì
questo è un momento in cui stavamo
montando nel piano della foresta un
trasmettitore in ovviamente vedete che
forse non lo vedrete bene ma comunque
sono tutti autoctoni tutte persone del
posto e questo momento in cui uno dei
miei studenti che poi sulla scorta di
quel lavoro trovò in realtà occupazione
in un buon ente quindi diciamo agli
valsi anche un titolo di merito in cui
stava formando appunto le persone del
posto e devo dirvi che questa è
un'immagine che porto sempre ad esempio
che una di quelle che mi danno
soddisfazione dai una scuola di dyou ma
prima scuola di dyou ma dopo
vabbè non applaudite troppo perché sennò
poi dopo perdiamoci mi tocca poi
troncare allora nel 2009
decidemmo di passare a qualcosa che
aveva a che fare con un contenuto
tecnologico non solo di tipo software ma
anche di tipo hardware a un po più
rilevante per cui partecipavamo un altro
bando questa volta lo stato del qatar
che è praticamente aveva proposto di
finanziamenti a enti di ricerca che
avessero delle idee un po particolare un
po interessanti e io avevo proposto un
ideale regione piemonte che venne
bocciatissima che era quella di
sviluppare una sonda che doveva
viaggiare nei tubi analizzare i rumori
fatti dall acqua nei tubi e per tramite
di onde radio riportarli informazioni
alla superficie perché perché in italia
il 50 per cento dell'acqua che viene
presa alla sorgente viene persa prima di
arrivare al destinatario che siete voi
il 50 per cento e solo acqua ma l'acqua
ma produrre l'acqua costa ma in italia
non viene fregato tanto è però in qatar
si la ci finanziano questo progetto tre
anni di finanziamento un finanziamento
adeguato e questo è il risultato che
venne presentato dal dicembre dell'anno
scorso e il water molla talpa d'acqua e
questo oggetto che naviga di tubi e
trova le perdite con una precisione i
dieci centimetri risparmiando tantissimo
tempo per andare individuare le perdite
anche per definirle quindi risparmiando
poi sugli scavi su tutta una serie di
cose annesse e connesse
allora visto e considerato che andare in
giro per le montagne per il pianeta
eccetera interessante ma comunque sia
home sweet home come si dice
allora nel 2010 decidemmo di andare a
tornare a lavorare vero savoia questa
volta non per aprire uno spot ma per
allestire un vero e proprio campo
sperimentale permanente dove tutti gli
utenti tutti i cittadini potessero
diventare utenti di un nostro sistema e
dove noi potessimo mettere metterci a
giocare con questo sistema e quindi
sviluppare tecnologia e quindi tentare e
analizzare delle possibili forme di
tecnologia che potessero poi essere
utili e replicate in giro per il mondo
ma soprattutto arrivare a costruire
delle vere e proprie reti organi che
magari mi permettessero di pensare ad
arrivare a coprire degli interi paesi
l'esperimento fu accolto con un successo
incredibile abili regaliamo banda tutti
quindi potete immaginare ma in ogni caso
vedete quella foto che c'è sulla destra
e una persona che in pieno inverno 2012
quello rigidissimo andò da solo a
ripulire i pannelli solari che sono
rappresentati ovviamente in altro
periodo sulla sinistra pur di riportare
il segnale la connettività a tutto il
comune e ci furono anche gli elementi
divertenti ad esempio visto che lasciamo
che la tecnologia venga installata è
montata dai singoli cittadini
e c'è la gente che le antenne e le
posizioni nei posti più strani adesso
parte gli occhiali da sole però c'era
uno che lo teneva direttamente e lo
premiamo perché riusciva a far
funzionare la rete nonostante tenesse la
sua antennina sullo sdraio quello sulla
destra ci ha provato a risparmiare i
soldi per non comprarsi l'antenna
assemblando quella specie di lava
insalata con i rasoi ma in quel caso la
parabola però comunque l'abbiamo
premiato lo stesso
voi qualcuno di voi che ha dimestichezza
con tecnologia sa che esiste arduino
arduino un progetto che prevede il fatto
di utilizzare piattaforme open hardware
quindi costo molto contenuto per
realizzare una serie di cose allora nel
2011 abbiamo esteso questo discorso del
dare connettività i miei concittadini
andando anche a portare dei dispositivi
che dovevano in qualche modo
semplificare la vita domestica quindi ad
esempio realizzare cose collegate ad
internet che permettono anche di
monitorare le temperature fare
assistenza ad esempio l'erogazione del
terreno ma la cosa più importante una
rete totalmente autonoma indipendente
che serve per l'assistenza domestica gli
anziani senza la necessità di essere
collegati a un telefonino alla rete
telefonica tradizionale eccetera
solo mediante copertura onde radio tutto
il paese con un costo irrisorio stiamo
parlando di un comune che ho da o queste
condizioni di al servizio d'assistenza
con una stazione radio base che costa la
bellezza di 15 euro nel 2012
sulla scorta degli nuovi esperimenti
averla insieme con la qatar university
vinciamo un'altra cosa che ci porta in
africa nel isole comore arcipelago
nell'oceano indiano uno degli stati più
poveri del pianeta e lì andiamo vedete
le condizioni potete avere delle
situazioni in cui le strade sono
drammaticamente interrotte mettiamo
insieme un'accozzaglia di gente
tra qatarini cubani io
eccetera eccetera ci divertiamo per
circa tre mesi e in quei tre mesi
andiamo a costruire delle cose che
permettono la copertura integrale
internet di tutto il territorio
passiamo ad una situazione incubo i nati
in giro per la giungla trovate magari un
telefono immesso così nell'ambito del
nulla a una situazione in cui avete
sempre lo spot è quella è la mia
realizzazione a cui tengo di più
all'interno di una palma sulla destra
2013 torniamo di nuovo in italia ci
mettiamo lavorare su tutta una serie di
cose
e questa in assoluto è l'oggetto a cui
tengo di più ultimamente questo è una
telecamera che monta lo stesso sistema
di trasmissione che è stato usato per
fare i 300 km per l'africa eccetera
questo sta all'interno di un vigneto
questo mi permette di controllare le
condizioni di vita di evoluzione delle
piante e mi permette di evitare
l'utilizzo di roba chimica di pesticidi
e di minimizzare anche l'utilizzo dello
zolfo e rame quindi a favore
dell'agricoltura sostenibile
questo oggetto alla capacità di
raccogliere informazioni su un range di
ovviamente 300 km adesso magari questo
non li fa però comunque con un costo che
è bassissimo e adesso abbiamo in
previsione di portarlo non solo nelle
vigne del piemonte ma anche in quelle
del chianti